[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
orgueil venir chris et moi c'est moi je
vous je ne connais pas rocco siffredi
habitude de le voir encoder mois
en clair se reconnaît pas alors qu
siffredi donc vous jouer dans un film de
catherine breillat qui sort le 14 avril
qui s'appelle romance avec caroline
ducey sagamore stévenin et françois
berléand alors on en parle beaucoup il
ya un gros buzz comme on dit chez les
jeunes c'est le premier film qui
transgresse les barrières entre le film
x de films pornos et le film d'auteur
alors on va en parler tout à l'heure
pendant l'émission on va on va y revenir
notamment avec jeanne labrune mais on va
commencer par parler de vous d'abord
puisque c'est effectivement un événement
que vous soyez dans un film d'auteur et
de longueur et de largeur longueur
largeur effectivement parfaite
conséquences alors vous êtes bon vous
êtes la plus grande j'ai pas la plus
grosse parce que mais là la plus grande
en tous les cas ces stars mais ça
commence on avait
et la jalousie les verras que tu vas
médicaux éviter la vulgarité mais juste
un morceau il est jaloux 8 cm on dirait
que c'est pas la sienne mais je parie
gros pénis mais c'est quoi un micro
pénis
on dit que c'est de fait de moins de 8
cm missiles valeurs et tout ça que tous
nos fans qu'elle s'égare à l'htap devant
derrière puisque on leur fait croire
tout le temps que ça ça fait 20 ans
on va avoir du mal
on ira au bout de la terre de libye ou
alors j'adore aller au bout
vous êtes là c'est qu'il est vachement
éloigné de perte de temps non plus en
hauteur vous êtes le alain delon du hard
est d'ailleurs votre nom rocco siffredi
vient de roch siffredi qu'est vous le
savez bien vous leurs griffes et anne un
cinéphile roch siffredi c'est le nom
sinon bravo
oui bien il connaît une chance pour ne
voulait pas disney 800 films
vous avez pratiqué 3500 fille jeudi
pratiquer comme ça et alors vous avez
une spécialité vous a une particularité
c'est que vous allez vous attendre une
érection à peu près tout le temps qu
enfin d'aider la jetterait plus j'aime
ce sont mes choix
quand j'étais plus jeune ça marche
beaucoup mieux dans le sens que c'est
pour ça c'était mon défaut qui a été un
grand un gant comment dirais-je
l'avantagé le négatif j'étais content je
les 12-13 ans par les as well on va
parler de notre enfance parce que ça ça
commence très fort vers 7-8 ans des
substances alors bon pour finir soit
pour finir sur notre pour rien sur les
célébrités vote chaix a été moulé et de
nombreuses femmes et de nombreux hommes
l'ont acheté maintenant il ya aussi une
poupée gonflable de vous qui existe
s'est passé pas très bon ça parce que
c'est pas vrai ma femme effectivement
elle m'aidait voilà avec toutes les
équipes ça peut le dire tant qu les
maintenant au tour à quelqu'un qui va
pouvoir acculé ce que j'avais à ma place
alors on va regarder un petit peu votre
votre vie votre historique hommes comme
disent les jo c'est parce que je devais
faut quand même dire que ici rocco
siffredi est là c'est parce que c'est le
petit ami la productrice catherine barma
qui me l'a imposé
arrive alors commencez pas à faire la
fine bouche c'est un gentil mademoiselle
joue dans une pièce de molière externe
en jeu comprend quasiment tous à poil
hier dur de nantes
molière dur demain bien
recours vous êtes né à orthez où donc
est une station balnéaire des abruzzes
et dornach toile et jusqu'à 7 8 ans vous
avez eu donc une enfance à peu près
normale et à partir de 7-8 ans vous avez
eu des coups de chaleur on peut appeler
ça comme ça et des coups de chaleur qui
veut donner une envie folle de venu de
vous masturber et qu'il sait ça et qui
était dû à votre métabolisme en fait
c'est ça oui je sais pas qu'est ce que
c'était mais j'arrivais parfois me
masturber au moins pendant dix fois dix
fois par jour mais parce que dès que je
finissais j'ai dit que j'irai l'orgasme
ça recommençait à l'intérieur c'est
terrible parce que à cet allègement on
compte déjà des gens ont tendance est
pas une grande ville on n'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir beaucoup dire qu'ils
ont des ailes à longvic et la
disposition pour poids face à ses
besoins de trouver une partenaire plus
courte et je me suis je me suis masturbé
jusqu'à l'album je me masturbe encore
aujourd'hui et je peux te le dire mais
je devais me temime masturbation
mauvaise baisse face au nord est et à
moi je suis vachement d'accord
[Applaudissements]
dans votre famille soit clair dans votre
famille la femme des antécédents c'est
un petit peu atavique parce que votre
père et c'est bon on cunnilingus
votre père était celle d'un gus
o'donnell dans le particulier dans la
dépêche connaît pas les histoires de ma
famille je sais que mon grand père sava
fait beaucoup de monde cette histoire
parce que c'est vrai mon grand père il
est mort à l'âge de 46 ans elle a eu ses
enfants avec une femme et 11 soldats et
il est mort et le boulot de mon bon mon
grand-père la somme un peu à mon boulot
de jouer parce qu' il avait 4 5 taureaux
et les gens ils aiment les des vaches
pour la montre a donc entamé un puissant
tir qui vient tout à l'heure on en parle
avec elle il a été tué et les états il a
effectué par un saut parce qu'il ya eu
un moment les gens ils aiment n'est pas
assez de vache son voeu est donc j'ai
trop ils avaient le sang noir noir donc
et il est allé pour renforcer les
chaînes elle a été un corner directement
d'accord à 9 ans vous aviez des
érections par le simple fait de donner
la main comme ça vous vous donner la
main
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon grand complexe
j'avais des biens sous j'avais des
béninois même dans la mer parce que
l'ordonnancé ville de mer je mettais des
maillots de bain beaucoup plus grand du
normal et souvent j'avais des complexes
terrible parce que je commençais fille
bonjour j'avais des sélections jamais
j'étais dans l'eau je lui parlais dans
l'eau je sais bien on comprenait pas et
c'est tout
mais comme ça chez nous cousteau il
s'appelait
[Applaudissements]
et préparer les sacs erich hess calenge
égale baugé guest dans la moule s'est
déjà passé sa vie à faire chier numéro
avec une lampe de poche timsit alors
donc vous étiez de timides à l'époque
comme si vous étiez en cédant des parts
et voilà comment voulez vous soyez
prêtre bonne maman elle voulait que vous
soyez c'est comme on appelle ça les les
enfants quand on a 10 ans née à côté du
plaid de la petite île non je fais ça
pendant douze ans mais avec la robe
comme ça c'est dit en voyant mes
maillots large médium et s était
toujours un cinglant j'étais comme deux
personnes moi même c'était très bizarre
et alors à saison donc vous en prie on
ne sait le grignon et lui disait 2 mai
valait le coup d'oeil en anglais à ses
horizons pouvez plus vous partez dans la
marine marchande cdu est terrible marché
marine marchande posait pas de femmes
sur les bateaux de la marine marchande
moment masturbation il me tend selon
maturation pendant un an à 17 ans vous
venez à paris d'un périscope votre frère
votre frère un restaurant à paris
oui vous rencontrez un juge vais vite
parce que vous rencontrez une cliente
qui vous emmène dans une boîte
échangiste et là vous rencontriez
relayait les pontets l'indépendance et
le pape jeté radan nitel moi c'était
comme un contrait de niro aujourd'hui
même que d'ordinaire mais c'est un peu
ça dans l'histoire parce que je voyais
seb ou 15 mai masturber dans ses
bouquins beaucoup moins dix ans avant
ouais la jaunisse effectivement je
connaissais toutes les filles qui avait
travaillé avec beaucoup défi platine
étaient beaux coups de feu nicolas cage
vide
c'était vraiment quelque chose pour moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'exceptionnel à vous découvrez que des
gens qui sont payés pour faire l'amour
quoique finalement c'est ça peut être un
boulot que c'est vraiment un boulot de
et alors vous commencez à prêt à faire
votre trou dans le milieu
bien nous serons complètement paniquée à
l'idée d'aller vraiment beaucoup
la différence avec ruquier la différence
avec lui qui sait que moi je quelques
bancs d'essai expression bien sûr et là
vous avez un problème vous avez - vous
marrer là vous avez un problème parce
que vous tombez amoureux d'une fille qui
s'appelle tina et elle veut que vous
arrêtiez le métier un made by mois auto
mais tiens moi je dis bon d'accord c'est
vraiment c'était dur pour vous avez
mangé des mangé la même a rien à manger
je fais beaucoup de moi sans rien sur
dix en riant vie on vit on vit ses
romans d'amour est beaucoup de féliciter
avec donc après vous avez quitté tignes
êtes revenu dans dans le métier vous
êtes devenu la star c'est le mal et
c'est ce passé à la fin parce que l'on
pouvait plus parce que de toute façon
moi j'ai pas tellement je n'ai pas en
faisait l'amour tout le temps et elle
m'a regretté le fait que le cetim
manichéenne des nues qu'elle avait un
tout petit sexe très fermé très beau
très comme heroes après trois ans avec
moi c'est bienvenu
ouais
[Applaudissements]
on voulait poser des questions
l'amérique est le 2009 sous la manche 6
moi je dis que moi aujourd'hui doivent
pas c'est vachement bien de dire ça mais
là visiblement de ce qui s'est passé
s'est passé le bêta c'est ce que nous
explique sam on en aurait tous voulu s
établir à temps on va faire un polaroïd
de tech ou pinèdes quand je dors à aider
mali avec mon énorme bazar
quand les chirurgiens être fasse un truc
normal si on n'a pas une photo d'avant
on va être là mais rubin messieurs
mesdames et messieurs
jean marie bigard vraiment les meilleurs
est arrivé ici pour nous parler de son
film
exactement alors que d'amour ouais
vraiment la goutte de citron sur la
chaîne e
quant à catherine jacob morte de rire
vous savez ça vous ça vous sarkozy tu
pas poser les questions ravis puisque
est question les réponses en même temps
que vous écoutez j'ai 20 ans j'ai eu une
belle vie je me suis beaucoup amusé et
j'ai vu d'aidé aux mba mais c'était une
tuerie
alors maintenant une question rocco
siffredi bon vous réussissez beaucoup
parce que vous faites vous faites jamais
semblant fait j'avoue quand vous faites
l'amour du vote secret en fait moi votre
succès c'est que vous ne faites pas
semblant contre dsk si cela doit cesser
il ya les glandeurs est distincte est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous parler italien
à l'oreille des de vos partenaires les
américaines fda américaine et me demande
même si l'italienne parlez vous vous
êtes en train de faire l'amour
très bien une italienne non à catherine
jacob si vous faisiez l'amour auquel
vous ne diriez quoi comme phrase en
italie en italie mollet qui j'ai des
enfants s'est plaint en italien en
italien en italie l'apport 4 bon de
toute façon c'est une histoire d'argent
mais plus je vous le mets quand même
complètement changé aujourd'hui je suis
pas docteur jeu produit haut de gamme
on passera aux histoires de production
parce que là j'ai des petites critiques
à vous faire des petits reproches à vous
faire oui aux coopératives ou alors est
ce que votre sexe est assurée j'ai fait
mais il me manque plus assurés parce que
la lloyd's pour pas perdre leur
réputation ils m'ont dit oui mais à
condition qu'on vient sur le fait on
vous assure avant le tout avant le
tournage et il faut qu'on soit là moi ça
me démangeait un peu ça parce qu'ils
m'ont dit l'assureur soit l' elysée
l'idéologie athée mais tous ne sont pas
pour l'impuissance normand pour la
question il disait ou faisait attention
à ne pas lui est rayé le casque ne suis
jamais arrivé qui est fille m'a mordu sa
réélection alors les problèmes comme de
petits problèmes
de petites boulettes il ya eu 120 de
boulaq il ya de petites boulettes
il ya eu 110 que tu ne risques pas dit
mais pas bien vu les siens
une suissesse de belle famille qui vous
a écrit pour travailler avec vous la
fait venir à rome c'est un film que vous
produisez et voulait les premiers oui et
vous la livrer quand même à 20 bonhomme
quoi et la fille salut à 20,20 type vava
hommes c'est pas écrit ce lien peut
tourner la tête revient à fréquenter les
retourner à genève elle est un peu un
concours fait des histoires du deuxième
affaire c'est sidonie par là c'est donc
voulu vous lui faites l'amour dans les
toilettes
les chiots dans les faits vous tirez la
chasse c'est le même film
c'est quand même pas très sympa non
c'est pas une question d'être pas sympa
c'est qu'ils soient par rapport à les
gens qui voient parler d elles
connaissent pas la réalité c'est pas
sympa mais ça
mais non mais si je vous ai cette fois
les gars si vous combien des questions
cdc des questions très simples pour le
temps il faut que les gens comprennent
bien ce que c'est ça qui se passe parce
que sinon il peut penser alors que les
gardes en forêt de la trappe la tête lui
mais dans les choux il tirait et tire la
chasse - biesheim c'est les films avec
des gens qui ont envie de faire des
fantasmes oeuvré pendant et les femmes
non et les femmes et sont beaucoup plus
pervers que l'ombre parce que l'homme tu
veux mais d'où femme à côté et ils ce
sont les rois de la terre une femme ça
se passe tout de la tête et donc la
femme elle est beaucoup plus compliqué
de sa crise on y pense pour exciter une
femme il faut beaucoup plus maintenant
avec ce je veux pas dire qu'il faut lui
mettre un tel choc avec pas rien qui
vous a répondu ok merci
oui bien sûr j'ai sur le fantasme que
vous n'avez jamais réalisé qu'ils vous
restent aujourd'hui encore il y en a
beaucoup pour moi pour moi le fantasme
vrai c'est voir une femme qui me regarde
dans les yeux mais des baisses moins
dans les yeux et n'importe comment on le
fait sans limite donc face m
c'est toujours mon fantasme au courant
dames et demoiselles vous êtes prévenus
donc vous rencontrer si vous regardez
dans les yeux là comme ça vous lui dites
ce qu'il vient de dire allez voir alors
on continue
en 1993 on est on arrive à vous
rencontrer là d'un coup ce qui est
formidable d'ailleurs dans cette
histoire c'est pour ça que c'est qu'elle
a il tombe sur une fille qui s'appelle
rosa il tournait un film à fidji makan
qui s'appelait bodyguard et en cette
fille bon vous la connaissez dans un
film allait hongroise 1 et le matin où
vous tourner avec elle le fait que vous
fassiez l'amour avec d'autres filles ça
la fait pleurer à midi elle sort elle
sort du tournage en larmes et donc vous
êtes mariés en 96 vous avez vu vous avez
un enfant mais j'attends la 12e
enfin on va regarder alors vous allez
voir rocco siffredi très différent de
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer
voilà ce que rosa est arrivé à faire
bravo rose à ce que rosa est arrivé à
faire de rocco siffredi serge c'est de
chez quelqu'un parce que je me suis déçu
je cherche je me trouvais mais en fait
je trouve quelqu'un me très belle et
très très très important c'est notre vie
ce maître monde quelqu'un c'est pas un
jeu de ma femme c'est tout comme un jeu
lui qui comptait sur tf1 mes cheveux je
sais c'est complètement con et je me dis
c'est un petit singe je m'en fous mais
moi j'ai pas envie d'entrer chez moi au
mois de mai l'accès un peu avec ma femme
aussi elle est très familier là au lieu
de rentrer on n'est pas fatigués
physiquement plutôt un peu
psychologiquement et en même temps la
fatigue
chaque fois que j'avais la niaque 120
parce que psychologiquement je suis pas
s'allier pour rien ça m'a vraiment
changé d'avis parce qu'il m'a donné
beaucoup de choses qui avancent je me
disais je rêvais son mandat voir et j'ai
jamais eu
et en fait je ne suis jamais toujours
dit jamais je jouerai ma femme c'est ça
mon amour c'est dans ma tête et dans mon
cas c'est tout le temps là et je sors le
matin je pensais et je rappelle tout le
temps elle m'appelle donc ma femme c'est
mon amour je veux absolument occupé de
mon iphone est vraiment absolument
sûrement absolument je veux lui surtout
les choses qu'ils ne préfèrent le fais
mais je passe à un enfant là je suis à
rosas beau tu fais la fin du chantier du
fait ça je vais travailler je ramais ne
sont absolument pas il faut qu on
partage le bébé les deux bouts magnéto
et fiable à la mer
tout cela
[Musique]
moi je pense
[Applaudissements]
c'est arrivé apprivoiser rocco siffredi
et les forces est rosa alors dites moi
vous trouvez pas qu'il est formidable
avec son bébé la géniale idée géniale
tout le temps les balles il dit
simplement les choses s'étaient s'éteint
c'est un homme qui est très respectable
tout cas et toute mon amitié
[Applaudissements]
il est resté ferai pas ce qui pourrait
en avoir marre quoi au bout d'un moment
je vous trouvez vous le trouvez frais de
trouver naturel
je trouve c'est le contraint à perdre et
c'est une émission finalement qui tourne
très fille lola une porno et le vix à la
politique parce que ségolène royal il ya
peu de temps vous le savez thierry a
déclaré qu'il fallait supprimer le film
porno sur canal+ parce que c'était
dangereux pour les enfants qui pouvaient
tomber par hasard là dessus alors moi je
dis aux parents qui ont des enfants qui
par hasard pourrait tomber sur un film
porno que c'est pas très grave si vos
enfants tombent sur des images de films
porno on n'avait qu'à leur dire c'est
pas grave c'est de la politique le
monsieur et madame ils sont en train de
négocier un contrat pour l fin
[Applaudissements]
alors doit compter dans ce livre aussi
prédit notre enfance alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya deux points quand même très
intéressant c'est que vous êtes né sous
le signe du taureau puis et que votre
grand père était éleveur de taureaux
reproducteurs oui signe du d'espérer une
prédestination évidente évidemment à
mais vous étiez enfant de coeur quand
vous étiez petit oui fait plus ou moins
une imposition liées à la culture
italienne donc ma mère il tenait
beaucoup que tous les dimanches à
l'église et elle tenait beaucoup qu'un
de ses fils ses garçons un seul est bien
prête comme j'étais le plus grand le
plus haut et plus ou moins elle aurait
adoré mais malheureusement pour une fois
on peut plein dans l'écurie
alors quand je fais un beat j'ai ma
carte 10 à 3 ans la désactiver alors
première masturbation à l'âge de 10 ans
c'est sur le tard sa poche tous les
temps d'aujourd'hui oui
ouais ça c'est le paradis il avoue
découvrir autre chose
la vraie vie la vraie vie et votre mère
qui est en train de faire la lessive sur
la terrasse vous voit par la lucarne des
toilettes et vous vous rendez compte que
votre mère vous voit en train de vous
masturber blessé deux heures ont été
dressés à la vraie honte mais je dois
dire que j'ai eu vraiment une grand
grand grand grand mère c'est grâce à
elle que je suis je suis aujourd'hui
c'est grâce à elle que parce qu'elle
elle m'a jamais fait pc-7 cette histoire
dressant je suis sortie de toilettes je
m'attendais laisser ces jeux ma tombe et
n'importe quoi il m'a donné un regard
sur dix ans mon fils il a grandi mais
elle n'a pas voulu émettre aucun
pression alors voilà donc l'été dosettes
garçon de plage et là vous avez une
libido très très embarrassante parce
qu'il suffit que vous voyez trois poils
pubiens qui dépasse d'un bikini et de
parasols
mais ça c'est ça c'est la réalité mais
c'est pire parce que je me savais qu je
vécu toute mon adolescence très très mal
soi-disant avec l'essor de complexe
parce qu'à l'époque on avait des
maillots très serré oui et je me
souviens qu'ils d'accord on me paye
santé une copine et c'était enchanté moi
j'avais une érection donc j'avais une
entité richir ange michel daloz suivant
et les filles comprenait pas pourquoi je
lui paraît dans l'eau et c'était
vraiment très très mal à l'aise cette
histoire
à l'époque j'étais tellement masturber
voit quelques vous avez une cystite
chronique de livrer corps et des
ampoules terrible tous ces histoires que
vous ayez qui vous lisent et d un de ces
livres qui a pas de tous la paix tension
d'être en livre havre et un livre dont
vous trouvez quelque chose d'extrêmement
littéraire pas du tout parce qu'ils se
moquent je l'écris par rapport à
plusieurs problèmes un premier jet
moi je trouve que c'est très intéressant
justement parce qu'il est vrai nom je
vous raconter des trucs extraordinaires
les tournois de brawn est pas encore
vous faites les tomates branlette il
comme il arrive à faire 11 éjaculation
en six heures comme c'est énorme mais
vous sauviez dalle et on a le temps moi
je n'ai pas trop l'école je faisais
partie de ces garçons qui étaient au
dernier rebond et qu'ils se brûleraient
on regarde on la prof d'anglais
si vous voulez je faisais partie de
cette catégorie est donc je vais un ami
à moi roberto poli johnny qui était haut
adour se passer les magazines on se
passait des histoires et on organiser
les tournois de branlette donc qui
voulaient participer il n'allait pas
l'école 8h30 devant l'école en sortez et
on se représenter on allait en dessous
des tournants vous savez un pin est en
tout cas un cachet et ont passé des
heures à se branler mais c'est vrai que
c'était une une situation très naturel
en europe en est entre mecs il faut je
crois d'avoir style eu le record de
l'époque parce que cette fois il ya
personne qui n'a pas déjà culation en
six heures c'est vrai qu' à l'époque
c'était c'est un jeu mais après c'est
devenu un problème lié au fait qu'il
commence à vous et je commençais à avoir
sérieusement des problèmes de brûlures
l'arrêt est donc plus je me masturbe et
plus se brûler et la façon d'y arriver
la brûlure s'était masturbé de plus donc
c'était un jeu vicieux alors après bon
fait vos premiers jobs vous êtes
manoeuvre ensuite vous engagé dans la
marine
et puis un jour j'en ai marre vous
débarquez à paris chez votre frère
armando amende de 1 voilà qu'est patron
d'un restaurant d'agir casa nostra
j 17 ans là dans un premier temps
beaucoup de conquêtes beaucoup de
conquêtes féminines
oui à idées j'ai fait jouer cliente du
restaurant qui n'est qu'habiter au
dessus et puis à 20 ans vous découvrez
un club échangiste qui s'appelle chez
denise leur accès aux 106 maintenant
c'est aux 41 enfin c'est un mot elle
aime toujours son show et tous les soirs
après le boulot vous y allez pour leur
part tout un sens et vous prenez un
petit peu la coqueluche de cet endroit
ça faisait longtemps avant que j'avais
demandé à mon frère hermann d'eau est ce
que tu connais quelqu'un qui fait des
films pour jean m'a dit mais tu es fou
de quoi tu cherches mais à l'époque y
avait pas il n'y avait pas la vidéo il y
avait que le cinéma en 35 cm dont 35 cm
excusez-moi 35 me
mm 35 mm et malheureusement je le dis il
n'y avait aucun droit je pouvais rentrer
dedans donc par rapport à tout ça par
rapport à tout ça l'histoire ce que mon
frère ne pouvait pas m'aider le seul
endroit qui gelait intéresser les boîtes
échangistes
mais tu te fais est pas rentré à
l'époque tout seul il faut y aller
accompagné par une fille c'est toujours
pareil donc je connaissais les filets
gamine de 18 ans j'avais 19 ans donc je
connaissais les gagne 1,17 sais je me
fait je vais pas lui demander ce que tu
m'accompagnes des boîtes à changer selon
elle en prend pour un fou
donc c'était la femme de 40 ans je
connais belle femme de 40 ans je sors
avec finalement en termine au lit comme
je voulais je lui ai posé la question
tout de suite après midi lors comme
était fou et comme on fait rire après
unis mais pourquoi les dauphins dans un
endroit comme ça la réalité c'est qu'ils
jouent les voir qu'est ce qui se passe
dans ces endroits et je dois avouer
qu'ils aient dès que je suis rentré qui
m'ont fait rentrer j'ai son petit nerf
très familière non mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est la seule à réaliser je me
suis senti chez toi jusqu'au jour où tu
rencontres au 106 super sexe en super
c'est que c'est un titre dont tu étais
fan quand tu étais jeune parce qu'il y
avait tous les les journaux et c'était
le déni raw pour quelqu'un ici pierre
richard pour quelqu'un ici
bien ça veut dire quelqu'un de très
simple c'est une star du porno italien
il s'appelle tout court et voilà c'est
une chaussure noire
[Rires]
il s'appelle gabriel et pomper l'eau
dans lequel il a toujours dit qu'il est
italien
il est français je sais qu'il est très
bien français bon l'histoire c'est une
autre c'est que pour moi le voir en vrai
après m'être m'assumer milliers de fois
avec sa figure c'était quelque chose
d'incroyable donc le voir en vrai il
était accompagné par deux belles femmes
m'a dit avec son gros cigare il me fais
toi ta grosse bille toi tu le best ou
thomas bien je vis près ça me plaît mais
il faut voir que tu sais faire il m'a
passé les 12 mai on fasse 200 personnes
je suis restée 12 heures là je me suis
amusé les jeunes apej et thermos et tout
cela comment il a trouvé du travail
seule chose que c'est une audition quoi
ça donne castille solutions ouvrir ces
essais gabriel qui te présente à marc
dorcel et voilà comment la carrière
toujours de son image en photo il faut
dire que j'ai débuté avec platine est je
tiens le dire parce que ça reste la plus
belle actrice française c'est ses
platines est ce son mandat je nous
rappelle régine
même si elle reste la plus belle la plus
belle porno star française qui j'ai
jamais connue j'ai débuté avec la plus
belle celle à marly moreau non c'était
vraiment impossible à coucher avec je
vous préviens baiser parce que alors ce
qui est terrible c'est que le premier
jour tu as tellement peur de jouir tout
de suite qu avant le premier tournage tu
vas te masturber dans les chiottes
oui il a une facilité et on dirait pas
celle à ses mains sur la table
à l'époque il faut dire une chose il
faut dire vraiment les choses un moment
là c'est un moment très important de ma
carrière
j'ouvre la porte de cet appartement 15e
arrondissement et je me trouve indesign
et nana qui se promènent à droite à
gauche avec des porte jarretelles de
talons aiguilles
mon cerveau il a explosé je suis rentré
avec un pied dans un autre univers et je
me suis dit les mots ma tête allait
exploser je suis parti aux toilettes à
me branler parce que j'étais sur les
ferries mauvaise figure bien si j'en ai
fait quand même parce que c'était trop
fort les émotions c'était trop trop fort
c'est pas facile les tournages début
parce que les les collègues sont jaloux
il serait candidat à l'est à l'époque
c'était beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
malin c'était il y en avait un je me
suis bien là grand léjon l'appeler jean
pierre armand
moi je suis pas tombé sur lui je suis
tombé sur un virus qui est il m'a pas
gâté non plus parce que il était moi je
t'ai débuts avec les douches et les deux
fils étaient prêtes à poils très très
très très joli il y avait une blonde
française et notre chaîne donc andré vie
nous il était à genoux et se masturber
pour se préparer moi je t'ai en érection
non les filles je n'avais pas besoin de
magie mais parce que la vision ça suffit
et je me disais mais pourquoi qui se
masturbe il est fou donc à partir de là
il me dit qu'au fait tousser j'avais
fais toi te soucier moi aimer mais là je
me maquille g parce que tout d'un coup
d'un qui jaillit pas me tenir jugé qu
avant que la caméra par oui c'est la
ville d'ivry on y va on y va maintenant
on y va
moi je reste comme un couillon mail
l'histoire vraie et qui m'a tellement
piégée qui m'a il m'a complètement fou
tu as l'air donc je suis parti au bar à
33k momies pour me calmer je danse
me faire recommencer mais c'était j'ai
eu de la chance à l'époque parce que tu
es à ton travail le premier jour oui je
me suis dit je me suis dit vraiment vous
pouviez pas imaginé dans ma tête qu'est
ce qui se passe parce que je me disais
je tout foutu en l'air
je me suis fait piéger commun comme un
gamin me vois pas facile à l'époque
parce qu'un jour présente sera content
tu tombes sur alicia monnaie bah ouais
ça fait un mauvais score l'habite
après après m'avoir péter dans la future
[Rires]
la vie après m'avoir péter de la figure
c'est six journées terribles dans les
films comiques on le fait ce sont ces
semblants l'a7 evry saturé moi c'était
autre chose
[Musique]
c'est un fait ils tous les jours le
cinéma qui tournaient dans cinq jours
par mois on plus alliés pas de saisie
d'une époque où il y avait une époque
avec sté les argos qui peut-être
quelqu'un l'a connaît pour moi c'était
la pluie c'était vraiment la fille qui
allait être prêté pendant huit heures
jamais demandé de l'oubli l'oubli fiq
ont rien les actrices américaines s
arrêtait pas lui brise le blésois de fac
sd selon le blogueur elle rien nous on a
voulu vérifier comme noël c'était à
toulouse briller devant et derrière
et alors à un moment recours vous mettez
votre vie d'acteur entre parenthèses
parce que vous rencontrez tina oui dont
vous tombez très amoureux et là avec
elle une relation sexuelle très violente
un très belle très fort très passionné
jusqu'au moment où j'ai est celle celle
qui m'a initié d'ainsi sexualité
différente est un peu maso je crois
qu'on peut le dire n'ont peut-être très
fort oui parce que je me souviens une
fois pendant l été des plus en plus il
avait de plus en plus envie pendant que
je la prends que je une fois je me
souviens je le prends des jeux le
problème et je connaissais pas tous à
elle m'a giflé je lui remets j'ai fait
léger recul hélas un orgasme et à partir
de là à partir de là c'est devenu un peu
bizarre parce qu'elle n'arrêtait pas de
me lier à chaque fois qu'on avait un
problème de toute façon la seule chose
que tu sais faire cette bct pantalon et
je lui dit une femme une fois je
l'acceptent à la prochaine fois je
l'accepterais pas parce que j'ai laissé
mon boulot pour toi ouais donc pour
regarder ça vous étiez mannequin je suis
soit d'essence était un métier trop
difficile pour moi parce que mon corps
il est parfait pour être mannequin dans
cette situation je les trie malo vivait
vraiment au mois près je me souviens à
dte manger des spaghettis en blond
pendant un mois parce qu'on n'avait pas
de sous c'est angie mais on était
content je veux être amoureux n'avoir
pas de sousse est mauvaise et bien c'est
super mais c'est pas bien contre le feu
contre le feu 6 et 1 1
il ya que du simple que vais je me suis
en vers la fin je lui fais une connerie
je fais quelque chose de mauvais et
darren helm a plus laissé que je la
touche pendant six mois donc elles
passées à lire son livre
et moi je me branler aux toilettes on
regarde on health care
il a passé cinq pièces dont beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup j'ai écrite à
la porte des toilettes ça va très
important est sans fin des salons mais
même dans les films beaucoup de joie
beaucoup de fois c'est pas femmes tout
même dans un film ensuite vous reprenez
votre travail de deuil de porno star
c'est le grand succès aux états unis
et puis aussi la jalousie parce que vous
devenu une espèce d'icône
alors on raconte les pires conneries sur
vous en dit vous êtes violent avec les
actrices indique janvier le sida enfin
rien n'y fait vous êtes une énorme star
rien ne vous atteint et alors chez votre
mère en italie il ya des gens qui
viennent les bressans qui viennent en
procession voir sa mère c'est quand même
la mère de rocco siffredi la baronne est
alors sa mère elle dit attendez vous
êtes gentil j'ai fait une [ __ ] comme ça
ils ont fait ce qu il en veut
j'ai eu de la chance parce que je suis
un gars en ce jour était une fille sur
le titre est difficile mon père m'a
toujours dit qu'une quête non moins
facile pour une fille alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça peut mais mais je veux
dire
en italie la mentalité bien sûr si tu es
un homme mon père m'a toujours dit tu
baisses dit fille super mais ne me fait
pas attendre que tout chamekh donc si tu
veux c'est comme ça alors à 40 ans vous
arrêter pour plusieurs raisons
malheureusement parce que ma
personnalité d'italiens ressort à 40 ans
avec mes gosses qui grandissent ma femme
et qui pendant 13 ans elle a été
toujours là disponibles et m'a toujours
laissé ces contrats signés vas-y
t'inquiète pas il ya aucun problème
donc quand on a cet genre de situation à
un milliard ça fait que deux peut-être
ma mentalité italienne même si je
l'avais pressés à l'intérieur de moi
reçoit dix mois est-ce que c'est pas
aussi des problèmes de prostate qui vous
vous arrêtez pas du tout parce que ça
fait dix ans que j'arrive pas dormir une
nuit entière j'ai besoin de me lever
pour aller uriner donc c'est pas de
maintenant ça fait dix ans que je ne
sais pas mais c'est lié je pense la
prostate a été trop sollicité un bruit
parce que quand on fait 25 jours par
mois avec 12,3 déjà quinze jours c'est
bien sûr évident que ont su licite trop
la prostate avec le dois aussi c'est à
dire en dessous les
qoui commodity bien sûr aux vignes les
roubignoles un testicule les testicules
donc on pousse on pousse et pour faire
sortir parfois du sperme qui à la limite
ça ressemble plus à de l'eau minérale
ouais c'est sait on dirait que les gens
y croient pas mais c'est vraiment comme
ça 21 jours par mois aux 25 jours par
mois 2 3 et orgasme pajot ça fait
beaucoup
alors là certain nombre de mails de
téléspectateurs
on pense à quoi pour bandés pendant des
heures moi je peux vous dire à quoi je
pense pour pas y circuler pas nombreux
c'est parce que parfois ça m'arrive de
tourner avec des filles qui sont
sublimes trop belle ouais pour notre
belle et l'a donc au début de ma
carrière je me suis bien soûl d'épicier
le partout où je faisais semblant
d'avoir un caillou je faisais oh [ __ ]
mais qu'est ce qu'il y a pour sortir
habite parce que sinon j'allais gétules
et parce qu'elle bougeait trop bien ça
m'arrive aussi avec ma femme donc je
veux dire l'important c'est pas paniquer
tu la sors tu embrasses la fille tu fais
autre chose ça descend la pression tu
recommences après et tu retrouvé tous
rétablis la pression et peinture bush
faisant du zèle et aucun problème à la
cram âge toujours est-ce qu'on peut
réussir dans le porno sont couchés oh
bien sûr que oui c'est déjà assez déjà
pas mal je veux bien vous fait quoi que
tout le monde se branle de vos films ça
me fait plaisir en tant que spécialiste
roku sait combien le bon nombre pour une
partouze ça dépend ça peut être aussi
dit persan ça peut être amusant personne
c'est bien oui mais il faut des gens
bien il faut pas des gens qui se mêle à
dormir quand vous étiez une star du x
est ce que vous rameniez du boulot à la
maison le soir on on parlait de ça ce
matin avec ma femme elle m'a dit [ __ ]
t'as changé depuis que je te connais au
début c'était vraiment mécano un
vainqueur c'est ma femme qui lui dit
denis ranque ip départ il ya double
peiné à la radio alors coup c'est
catherine breillat qui vous et donnez
votre premier rôle dans le cinéma
traditionnel
vous l'avez remercier comment peut-être
un vraiment sincèrement j'aurais dû la
remercier mieux mais parce qu'elle est
vraiment elle m'a donné une grande
chance de connaître
qu'est-ce que c'était le vrai cinéma
donc catherine bréard merci merci merci
c'est tout mais merci c'est tout
qu'est-ce que je fasse
alors merci on se demande toujours
comment vivent les vieux acteurs qui ont
fait du porno une double pénétration
c'est combien de points de retraite je
prêt calculé ça j'aurai beaucoup de
retraite une autre violence et 3 points
en moins
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui roque aussi
une fois par semaine le samedi soir dans
la position du missionnaire et après
basta pas du tout vrai jeudi j'ai dit ça
m'arrive de ne pas le faire pendant une
semaine mais ça m'arrive de le faire
aussi semaine tous les jours
évidemment je demande à un peu complexé
on a un peu jaloux par rapport à vous
recommandons va faire l'interview même
rocco
[Musique]
est-ce que même rocco aimerait avoir un
sexe plus grands parfois écouter
dernièrement je n'ai vu quelqu'un
d'américains qui a débarqué vraiment
avec des 30 cm 3 et donc je me suis
sentie petty mais ça va bien ça va je
suis content de ça que j'avais combien
est-ce que même rocco a du mal à bander
parfois oui est-ce que même rocco a du
mal à revendre et parfois plutôt ça
est-ce que même rocco a déjà pensé que
sa femme simulaient jamais est-ce que
même recours est déjà galéré pour
séduire une fille oui beaucoup de fois
est-ce que même rocco a déjà pris des
râteaux il a le mange déjà deux fois
est-ce que même rocco s'est déjà fait
traiter de petit beat psychologiquement
oui est-ce que même rocco a déjà pensé
qu'il n'est pas que le cul dans la vie
beaucoup de fois c'est difficile est-ce
que même recours pense que le plus
important c'est la tendresse
oui mais aussi avec le reste avec la
double peine non mais je pense qu'elle
va avec leur s il faut jamais être dur
sans l'attendre et ça marche pas mais
sont dans des bisous avancer beaucoup
mieux c'est le secret de m corner voilà
est-ce que même récompense que les films
x ont une influence néfaste
moi je pense que comme tous les autres
choses de la vie la télé les jeux
tout ça qu'on nous montre toute la
journée c'est au même niveau je penserai
jamais que la pornographie c'est
éducatif éducatif mais aussi le
contraire donc je dis gdd exemple touché
à la main j'ai des gens qui me faire
mais dans la vie mais dis merci
d'exister moi je dis [ __ ] je suis pas
dieu mais il me dit comme ça et je des
autres qui me disent mais qu'est ce que
vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites que son qg les
deux qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je me
dis ouais est-ce que même rocco se dit
parfois qu'il est anormal beaucoup de
fois